on va retrouver tout luc dupont de
l'université d'ottawa chercheur associé
à l'observatoire des médias sociaux en
relations publiques bonsoir bonsoir que
cherche à faire et le mot ce qui selon
vous
il a parlé d'une place publique virtuel
un carrefour donc dans lequel on
échangerait des idées pour s'assurer que
tout soit fait dans le respect des uns
et les autres un algorithme vous disiez
il fait plutôt qu'ils seraient ouverts
donc ça c'est très important
il a parlé cet après midi lors d'un tête
à d'ailleurs les images envoyées
anticipé plus tôt était de cyril avant
coureur tente là il a dit ce serait la
fin des spams ou six pour connaître pour
les utilisateurs de twitter c'est assez
important et dérangent comme sénat mène
évidemment le fameux petit piton qui
vous permettrait de corriger une erreur
le cas échéant mais en ce qui me
concerne la plus grande surprise c'est
la disparition progressive de la
publicité donc contrairement à tector
sna facebook instagram l'idée ce n'est
pas d'augmenter les revenus
publicitaires mais de favoriser les
échanges et le respect des gens nous ont
ils parlent de liberté d'expression il a
critiqué twitter pour le manque de
liberté d'expression parce que twitter a
suspendu des comptes mais ce que la
liberté d'expression serait encore plus
en panne cissé il une masse qui possède
100% des actions ben c'est certainement
une question qu'on peut poser une
question qu'on peut poser aussi chaque
fois qu'un milliardaire décide de
prendre possession de la médium je pense
par exemple à jeff bezos avec le
washington post ou à d'autres aussi qui
ont investi récemment des sommes
colossales dans le magazine time pour
les garder en vie on nous dira toujours
initialement un peu d'ailleurs à
certains égards d'accord on a vu les
chiffres 2 instable de croissance mais
ce qu'on veut c'est aussi du côté
pourrait que ces questions tout 10 % des
gens représentent 90% de tous les
échanges et sur ce plan nord twitter est
un problème le deuxième problème de
twitter c'est con c'est somme toute peu
de choses sur les utilisateurs de
twitter contrairement à facebook
contrairement à cenon et contrairement
également la tple donc pour toutes ces
raisons les iob beaucoup de travail à
faire est ce que les noces de la
meilleure personne pour faire ça en tout
cas visiblement il maîtrise bien ici il
faut le reconnaître ou l'autre 60
millions de personnes
qui le suivent et il faisait justement
il en profiter encore aujourd'hui pour
faire un petit sondage ya une couple de
semaines ici où je viendrai il l'avait
demandé ce que vous avez sentiment que
tout est peint sur le plan de la liberté
d'expression fait un bon travail et à
hauteur de 70% donc au delà de deux
millions de votes donc c'est quand même
significatif les gens dit il ya place à
l'amélioration
le réseau social twitter c'est quand
même encore le neuvième site le plus
mondial le plus consulté mondialement on
parle de 2 milliards 400 millions de
visites en 2021 donc ce même si twitter
est quand même moins populaires que
facebook par exemple est ce que c'est
une plateforme qui est encore pertinente
aujourd'hui mais ce que nous et les
noces c'est que oui et là sur potentiel
de devenir l'espèce de carrefour
incontournable des échanges tout en
respectant aussi les législations des de
chacun des pays d'avoir ça c'est l'autre
défi évidemment de twitter mais
reconnaissons qu'il ya eu à travers le
temps des inconduites et qui font que
certaines personnes son rôle et d'autres
ne sont pas là certains propos sont
acceptées par simple et pas par d'autres
et que certains organismes aux
organisations sont là alors que d'autres
ne le sont pas et qu'on travaille dans
des univers et dans disons s'il n'a donc
de ce côté il ya certainement place à la
mire à 1 mais l'amélioration je pense
que ce que voient les lémance c'est un
extraordinaire potentiel ce que vous
avez identifié deux instances sont si ce
potentiel là absolument formidable mais
quand on cogne à la porte des revenus
force est de constater qu'un problème et
ça fait des années que ce problème là
persiste si on avez vous et moi
réinvesti en 2013 au moment où on a
lancé tout était la première fois autour
de 40 dollars l'action somme toute pour
notre patience on aurait été plus ou
moins bien et me wade exactement tesla
space x de boeing company on en parlait
en quoi cette nouvelle acquisition
rentre et rendrait cet homme là encore
plus puissant il serait cohérent dans ce
qu'il est en train de faire webb est ce
qu'on a constaté à tout le moins c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les investisseurs se sont
roussis une question toute simple oui il
est riche oui ils vont au delà de 1,5
milliard de dollars mais comment votre
super y ait cette acquisition là il a
réponse en tout cas si on s'en remet aux
investisseurs aujourd'hui le marché est
fascinant cet égard le marché a dit
probablement qu'il devrait vendre le cas
échéant certaines sections de tesla et
on a vu le cours de tesla reculer et
dans le code de twitter mais ce qu'on
peut penser que le marché nous dit que
lorsqu rats refusé d'ailleurs semblé
t-il que le conseil d'administration
s'est réuni ce matin autour des 10
heures et au moment où on se parle
d'ailleurs ce sont les employés de
twitter qui échangent les déçus et
semble-t-il là on n'est pas dans les
quatre murs des échanges mais semble
dire qu'on est vraiment mais vraiment
pas chaud à l'idée d'avoir comme futur
patron et l'annoncé way exactement
toiture qui consultent et qui étudie
officiellement si on veut toujours cette
proposition et on suivra ce qui va se
passer parce qu'on n'est pas un
soubresaut près avec les bonnes mains
luc dupont merci saint plaisir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit